i'm just here with my good friend elmo
yeah i know
yes because we both have talk shows
that's true which is so wonderful i'm
just learning a lot this is a much
bigger talk show that this is a swanky
place
we just we just do um almost talk show
in his apartment i gotta tell you i i
know you're set because i've been there
firsthand and it's magnificent you have
a big slide yeah
emma's not sure how we got it into the
apartment and almost not really sure how
we're gonna get it out
but we haven't we we do what we can with
what we have i think uh your show's
gonna be on for so long you're never
gonna have to worry about it
[Applause]
um well
elmo someone who's coming on is someone
that i really
look to as a really wonderful
interviewer oh cool yeah she's a young
journalist and someone i hold very dear
to my heart and she gave us so many
amazing moments last season and here's
our little love letter to our member of
the drew crew
she is a budding young journalist i love
asking questions and an internet
sensation gonna tell you guys a joke but
it's kind of inappropriate
she's the eight-year-old girl behind
seven questions with emmy the best
journalist in the business and a very
special member of drew's crew it's emmy
eaton are you ready to get into some
stories yes yes yes i'm so excited she's
already interviewed keith morrison
lester holt dr oz and on our show last
season she grilled seth meyers and
willie geist is it really hard to make
people laugh every day only my wife
armed with her quick wit and curiosity
emmy is here to deliver all the good
news you need more emmy the world needs
more emmy
and the dream comes true please welcome
for the first time ever in the actual
studio live and in person it's emmy e10
[Applause]
oh emmy i'm so glad that you're finally
here in new york city i'm so glad i
finally got to see you in person drew oh
my gosh i've been waiting for this
moment and i can't think of a more
special occasion
than to have our first time in person
get to be then with none other than elmo
you too
my little brother elliot loves you so
much yes hi elliot everyone loves you
too
okay i mean i heard that you had some
questions for elmo and i'd like you to
take over this interview okay okay
question number one how old are you
forty-four uh
question number two what's your favorite
food
hmm
well if elmo's being a good monster elmo
says uh apples
but don't tell anybody
pizza
you and ross matthews elmo
you're gonna have to come and try new
york pizza it's really good oh okay
maybe we can go for some pizza yeah okay
cool who's your best friend on sesame
street see i mean this is a very
difficult question
because if elmo says cookie monster
grover says hey wait a minute
you said cookie monster was your
favorite so elmo loves everybody equally
i think that's a great answer actually i
really do because i think you don't want
to hurt anybody's feelings and how can
you decide i know
big bird burton ernie rosita abby
there's so many i agree yeah i have a
bunch of best friends too and they
always ask me if they're my favorite and
i say all of
them you love everybody for different
reasons
yeah
what makes you laugh
well elmo's friends make elmo laughs
yeah someone likes your cookie monster
make someone laugh big bird um and you
know almost ticklish that's kind of
almost thing
so that makes someone laugh too
my little brother makes me laugh because
he always when your show comes on he
always goes
and then he thinks you're there in real
life so then he is like come give me a
hug
and then he gets so sad that you're not
there oh
that makes so much sad too
elliot emma wants you to know that you
could come to sesame street any time and
elmo will give you a hug what advice do
you have for me
it's sauce
wait wait i'ma think you're doing really
well already i don't think you have
great questions you're a really good
listener
um elma just thinks you should keep
doing what you're doing cause you're
gonna go really far thank you elmo
you're welcome i have to agree and i
think it's a miracle that all three of
us are together because we're all
curious
yeah that's true and if we can bring
that to our shows then we can be very
good at our jobs and ask people
questions and maybe when those people
give answers we can all have really good
takeaways from them very true
yeah i can't say it better than that
that was perfect oh my goodness well
thank you
thank you elmo
and thank you emmy my love
the not so late show with alma returns
on september 30th and is available to
stream on hbo max
[Music]